La pesadilla continúa aquí en Emilia
romaña la región sigue en alerta roja
por inundaciones el número de personas
evacuadas sigue aumentando 15.000
personas han debido a abandonar sus
hogares a causa de estas inundaciones
este sábado
las lluvias han retomado en varias zonas
afectadas para las autoridades italianas
es una verdadera Carrera contra el
tiempo para restaurar las
infraestructuras destruidas los puentes
las carreteras y liberar el acceso a
varios pueblos que todavía hoy
permanecen completamente aislados del
mundo para los habitantes atrapados en
estos lugares los equipos de Socorro
deben llevar alimentos y artículos de
primera necesidad en helicóptero y la
preocupación hoy es la enorme masa de
agua acumulada tierra dentro y que fluye
hacia el mar Esto hace que ahora es en
los pueblos de la costa adriática en
donde se esperan nuevas inundaciones hoy
claramente para los habitantes de aquí
el regreso a la normalidad será largo y
muy muy complicado